very very interesting and disturbing if
you believe that general david petraeus
former CIA director David Petraeus is
possibly going to be in Donald Trump's
cabinet uh Katie Couric who is the Yahoo
global news anchor interviewed Edward
Snowden in Moscow and Edward Snowden
said the former CIA director general
david petraeus disclosed quote
information that was far more highly
classified than I ever did and yet has
never spent a single day in jail again
this is relevant today because David
Petraeus is being considered for
Secretary of State in the incoming Trump
administration and this all started
talking about what's going on with
Snowden Snowden's lawyers in the US are
sort of worried about the Trump
administration and the possibility that
the Trump administration will take a
very hard line position against Snowden
so they either want a last-minute pardon
from President Obama or to negotiate
some kind of plea bargain that would
allow Snowden to come back to the United
States without having to spend a lot of
time in federal prison so Katie Couric
asked Edward Snowden well what kind of
plea bargain might you accept and Edward
Snowden said you know uh there are cases
like with David Petraeus were far worse
things were done than what i did and yet
there wasn't a single day served in
prison that's how Petraeus's name came
up and here's what Edward Snowden had to
say to Katie Couric what would a plea
deal look like for you you know I'm not
actually sure because I'm not a lawyer
but the idea here is when most people
who are involved in government or the
intelligence community are involved in
some sort of case where the government
goes this person was acting in good
faith they were trying to do right by
the American people but they did break
the law no charges were brought where
the brought very minimally perhaps the
best known case in recent history here
is General Petraeus who shared
information that was far more highly
classified
than I ever did with journalists and he
shared this information not with the
public for their benefit but with his
biographer and lover for personal
benefit conversations that had
information detailed information about
military special access programs it's
classified above top secret
conversations with the president's on
when the government came after him they
charged him with a misdemeanor he never
spent a single day in jail despite the
type of classified information he
exposed when we had the most senior
intelligence official in the United
States General James clapper who lied to
the American people and all of Congress
on camera under oath in the Senate in a
famous exchange with Ron Wyden he wasn't
even charge whatever you think about
Edward Snowden there is no doubt that
there are two justice systems in the
United States there are two sets of laws
but regardless there are also some
differences that are important to
recognize the information that General
David Petraeus gave his lover biographer
Broadwell uh is information that was not
used in her book about David Petraeus
and it was information that was not made
public however Petraeus did admit to
making a false statement to the FBI
about what he said and that is very
serious and it should be taken very
seriously there's an interesting tech
angle also which is that the way that
David Petraeus was communicating was MIT
with ms broadwell was that they were
using a regular old gmail account which
they would Draft emails they would
create an email and draft it but not
send it and then the other broadwell
would log in and she would be able to
read the draft that Petraeus had written
get the information that she needed and
then delete it and I wonder who thought
of that because you've got a guy who is
by many estimations a military genius
and apparently a total technological
[ __ ] for the CIA director pat to be
using the old let's use the unsent gmail
drafts method to
communicate that is something that drug
dealers have been caught doing that
something terrorists have been caught
doing and David Petraeus thought that it
was a good way to communicate very
classified information another
interesting angle to this too is Donald
Trump's neta pic for CIA director yet is
Mike Pompeo who actually called for the
execution of Edward Snowden right his
predecessor is David Petraeus welcome
and you'd have to imagine that he'd be
logically consistent if if he's gonna
call for the death penalty for Snowden
he would do the same for Petraeus right
yet uh well logical consistency I would
not hold my breath there as far as the
Trump administration is concerned I
think it's also important to distinguish
between leakers and whistleblowers
Edward Snowden is generally talking
about he had intent to help the American
people to be clear though Edward Snowden
did not expose crimes he exposed
completely concerning and ineffective
surveillance that had been legalized by
the government you can make the case it
shouldn't be legal you can make the case
that it's absolutely uh sort of
irrelevant in the global war on terror
to the extent that that you believe that
these techniques can or should be
disgusting fighting that global war on
terror but it is very different from
what Chelsea Manning for example exposed
so I think that it's relevant to talk
about to justice systems when we talk
about Snowden Manning Petraeus the
leaking or disclosing of classified
information but it's also very important
not to conflate a lot of these instances
just because you think something is
unethical doesn't mean that you are a
whistleblower if that action or thing
you're exposing is not against the law
and I know many people hear me say that
and I'll say but David it should be
against the law and that's perfectly
reasonable to say up but if it's not
legally speaking we're talking about two
different things